RACHEL: THANK YOU, GRIFF.
GREAT REPORTING.
TODAY WE HAVE WITH US AS WELL
KAYLEIGH McENANY, COHOST OF"
OUTNUMBERED" AND FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW
TODAY.
YOU SAW GRIFF’S REPORT.
WE KNOW THAT KAMALA HARRIS
HASN’T COME TO THE BORDER, WE
KNOW IT’S A DISASTER DOWN THERE.
DO YOU THINK THEY KNOW THAT IT’S
A DISASTER AND THAT THEY JUST
DON’T CARE?
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN?
>> I THINK THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT FIRST, I’D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN’T CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
FIRST DAY, RACHEL.
I LOVED WATCHING THOSE BEAUTIFUL
IMAGES OF YOUR FAMILY, AND I’M
SO HAPPY FOR YOU AND ALL OF YOUR
FOX COLLEAGUES, ME INCLUDED, ARE
CHEERING YOU ON.
RACHEL: THANK YOU.
>> THERE’S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT,
KAMALA HARRIS, JOE BIDEN, JEN
PSAKI ARE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
THOSE YOUNG GIRLS YOU SAW THROWN
OVER THE WALL, THAT
HEARTBREAKING VIDEO TO HAVE BOY
SAYING THEY LEFT ME, THEY LEFT
ME, THE FACT THAT WE’VE SEEN A
TRIPLE, THREEFOLD INCREASE OF
PEOPLE DYING CROSSING OUR
BORDER, IT SOUNDS HARSH BUT IT
IS TRUE, THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE.
WHEN YOU SAY THERE’S FREE HEALTH
CARE IN THIS COUNTRY IF YOU COME
ACROSS THE BORDER, WHEN YOU SAY
WE WILL OPEN CHILDREN WITH
OPEN -- WELCOME CHILDREN WITH
OPEN ARMS, DO NOT TAKE IT FROM
ME, TAKE IT FROM THE GUATEMALAN
PRESIDENT WHO SAID THAT VERY
THING, THE SAME PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS JUST SAT ACROSS FROM.
RACHEL: WE DON’T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME LEFT, BUT I DO WANT TO GET
YOUR THOUGHTS ON PUTIN.
HE SPOKE OUT AHEAD OF THE
MEETING WITH JOE BIDEN, HE
PRAISED YOUR FORMER BOSS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE CALLED PRESIDENT BIDEN A
CAREER MAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, WHAT’S HE UP
TO?
>> DOING WHAT HE’S ALWAYS DONE
WHICH IS MISLEAD THE MEDIA.
HOOK, LINE AND SINKER, HE
CONVINCED THIS COUNTRY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AN AT OF
RUSSIA.
THE MEDIA, THE BEST
PROPAGANDIST, CARRIED HIS WATER,
AND THAT’S WHAT HE’S DOING
AGAIN.
HE FEARED PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
PUT SANCTIONS ON HIM, WOULDN’T
ALLOW NORD STREAM 2 TO HAPPEN,
JOE BIDEN REVERSED IT AND
BASICALLY GREEN LIGHTED, AND IT
LEADS ME TO ASK AS DAVID
HARSANYI SAID AT "THE NEW YORK
POST," WHAT DOES VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAVE ON JOE BIDEN?
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS CARRYING
HIS WATER AND SO, TOO, IS THE
AMERICAN MEDIA.
RACHEL: GREAT POINT.